M it's God
it's it's
God it's
God hello man hello how you
doing good how are you man I'm pretty
good I'm a
Christian oh you're Christian okay yeah
so uh do you disag like are you like
came up because you uh like have a
question or like well you said Islam is
the only true monotheism I definitely
don't agree with that I believe that um
I think there's some problems with Ted I
think if if is if I don't think Islam is
true at all so like that's why I don't
think T would be true yeah okay I mean
it's you like I I don't say it's just
what you what you believe in I mean I I
believe that the Islam is why I'm saying
that because um
first of all um it's
the uh believe that is made to worship
the only like the the Creator and have
no one like besides him worshiping like
two or three or what his oness is you
know believe and also uh believe in
the um Angels believe in
the the the prophets who was sent by him
the books that was revealed to him their
resurrection and Al which means
preordination so what Allah has says
have came to pass so we believe in this
this is the like a building the F
fundation of it it's called
yeah I I understand we don't deny so
look look we don't deny anything so we
can't deny that what have um or create
have revealed to us we can't deny like
someone picking and someone like
rejecting I hear what you're saying I I
would say that like um when it comes to
Ted like um that tah is supposed to
resemble Allah's like his uniqueness
right and his like his uniqueness and
his attributes and um like he's the only
Lord he's the only one with these
attributes these Divine names right and
descriptions um but I would I would say
that there are some attributes that are
not unique to him you know like for
example Creator I believe that the Quran
talks about like Allah is supposed to be
the only Creator right um of life but
you also have Jesus in the Quran who's
also said to be a creator of life and so
I think that that would go against how
that Jesus is the creator say Jesus it
does yeah he created a a bird from clay
right okay so look look at me have you
read what he said when he created after
this what he said yeah he said he does
it by by Allah I can do nothing like my
own but the permission of Creator so he
saying if he didn't say that okay you
can't say like he he created it yes then
he's like but he said that he did it by
permission of his creator yeah he
doesn't he actually doesn't say that he
can't do anything without um the
permission of Allah but he does say that
he is creating this bird
as as real quick are
you yes I am are you God logic yeah yeah
I am so he doesn't
see they K the
guys just SC of what the heck coming
with different
account I knew that wasn't going to last
ladies and gentlemen we all knew that
that wasn't going to last but here where
it is as soon as you're putting the
pressure on the
Muslim uh and they they find out who you
are
they cower in the quickest way
possible so Jesus here he says that he
created a bird from clay he does it with
Allah's permission but by Allah's
permission Jesus is creating life so how
many creators is that my Muslim friends
Allah is one Jesus would be another oh
but it's by the permission of Allah okay
so by the permission of Allah Allah's
committing Sher by applying creation to
a a
creature by applying a Divine attribute
to a
creature right or else you want to say
that Jesus is God In the
Flesh him not doing anything outside of
the permission of Allah doesn't mean
that he doesn't have the innate ability
to do the creating himself
so you guys do with
that oh my godic
[Music]